[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
Steve Schwab liebt seine Routine
besonders abends
nach dem Abendessen sieht er eine Show
im Fernsehen dreht dann eine Runde mit
dem Hund durch Brentwood eine
wohlhabende Gegend von Los Angeles und
ist rechtzeitig gegen 23 Uhr für die
nächste Show auf seiner Watchlist zurück
am 12 juni 1994 schaut er die Dick van
Deich Show dann legt er seinen Hund an
die Leine und geht mit ihm nach draußen
doch diesmal bringt etwas die schöne
langweilige Routine durcheinander ein
anderer Hund ein schönes Tier mit Weiß
goldenem Fell ein Akita denkt Schwab
eine aus Japan stammende Rasse die als
stark robust und intelligent gilt und
als sehr treu man kennt vielleicht die
Geschichte eines Akita namens Hachiko
aus Japan der sein Herrchen jeden Tag
vom Bahnhof abholte und als sein alter
starb wartete
zehn Jahre Tag für Tag auf seine
Rückkehr bis er selbst starb
der agitar folgt schon er scheint
aufgeregt die Handschlaufe der
Hundeleine um seinen halsschleift hinter
ihm über den Gehweg
und da ist irgendetwas an seinen Pfoten
deutlich sichtbar auf dem weißen Fell
etwas Dunkles
Blut
Schwab glaubt der Hund sei verletzt er
beruhigt ihn und untersucht die Pfote
doch bis auf die Blutflecken ist alles
in Ordnung
weiß nicht was er mit dem anstellen soll
und lässt es zu dass der Hund ihn bis zu
seinem Haus begleitet
dort begegnet er seinem Nachbarn zu
klubobus der anbietet mit dem immer noch
aufgeregten Akita eine Runde zu drehen
damit er sich beruhigt und vielleicht
findet er ja auch Herrchen oder Frauchen
des Hundes
doch der Hund beruhigt sich nicht je
näher sie der Stelle kommen an der
überhaupt dem Akita begegnete desto
unruhiger wird das Tier
er zieht an der Leine
und der perfekt ist immer schwerer ihn
unter Kontrolle zu halten bis er
schließlich vor dem Haus 875 waren die
Drive stehen bleibt
das Haus liegt dunkel am Ende eines
langen Weges der Blick auf das Anwesen
ist von Bäumen und Büschen verstellt
einem ahnungslosen Spaziergänger wäre
nichts aufgefallen trotzdem aber lehnt
sich hinein versucht etwas zu erkennen
hofft jemanden zu sehen und sieht eine
Frau sie liegt am Fuß der Eingangstreppe
des Hauses und um sie herum ist alles
voller Blut
hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem täglichen True Crime
Podcast von Bild heute mit Teil 2 von
insgesamt dreien unserer Miniserie über
den Mordprozess gegen OJ Simpson mein
Name ist Tony Hayer und ich bin Mirko
Kasimir und wenn ihr den ersten Teil
dieser Serie gehört habt wisst ihr
natürlich schon wer die Frau ist die
leblos auf den Stufen ihres Hauses liegt
aber wir erzählen erst einmal
chronologisch weiter nach dieser
Entdeckung rennt borstepel zum Haus
einer Nachbarin und die ruft sofort die
Polizei ja ein bisschen zu schnell
vielleicht nämlich schon bevor Boss
tippe ihr von der Frau auf den Stufen
erzählen kann als der nämlich bei ihr an
der Tür klopft wird sie sofort nein one
one und meldet dass ein Einbrecher vor
ihrer Tür steht kurz darauf ist ein
Streifenwagen da doch nach dem klar wird
um was es hier wirklich geht trifft bald
Verstärkung ein
die Polizisten finden eine grauenvolle
Szenerie vor die Frau auf den Stufen ist
tot ihre Leiche liegt mit dem Gesicht
nach unten und barfuß am unteren Teil
der Treppe die zur offenstehenden
Haustür führt
der Gehweg vor der Treppe ist
blutverschmiert der Mörder hat ihr
mehrfach im Kopf und Hals gestochen und
dann der schon auf dem Boden liegenden
Frau den Hals mit solcher Kraft
aufgeschlitzt dass er ihr beinahe den
Kopf abgetrennt hätte
ganz in der Nähe finden die Polizisten
die Leiche eines 25-jährigen Mannes mit
Stichverletzungen an Kopf und Körper
auch in seinen Händen sind nur wenige
Abwehrverletzungen zu sehen ein
Gerichtsmediziner vermutet später dass
der Angreifer den jungen Mann mit einer
Hand erwürgte während er mit der anderen
auf ihn ein stach
bei der Leiche des jungen Mannes
entdeckten die Ermittler unter anderem
eine blaue Strickmütze und einen extra
großen leichten Lederhandschuh für die
linke Hand den wahrscheinlich
berühmtesten Handschuh der Welt eine
Spur von blutigen Schuhabdrücken
verläuft bis zur hinteren Tür des
Anwesens links neben den Abdrücken
verläuft eine Spur von Blutstropfen der
Angreifer muss eine Verletzung an der
linken Hand haben die beiden Opfer sind
schnell identifiziert es sind Nicole
Simpson braun und round Goldman ein
guter Freund von mir im Haus von Nicole
finden die Polizisten die beiden
gemeinsamen Kinder von Nicole Brown und
OJ Simpson Sydney und Justin sie haben
zum Glück geschlafen und den Mord an
ihrer Mutter nicht mit ansehen müssen
der vor Ort zuständige LEP die Commander
Kies schickt vier Detectives zum Haus
von OJ Simpson
sie sollen ihm die Nachricht vom Tod
seiner Exfrau überbringen und ihn zu
einer nahegelegenen Polizeiwache
begleiten um dort seine beiden Kinder
abzuholen
die Gebäude auf Simpsons luxuriösem und
weitläufigen Anwesen sind dunkel und
niemand reagiert auf das Klingeln der
Polizisten dann fällt Ihnen ein Wagen
auf og Simpsons Wagen ein Ford Bronco ja
aber nicht irgendein Ford Bronco es ist
der Ford Bronco ja aber so weit sind wir
noch nicht liebe Toni der Ford Bronco
ist in einem sehr merkwürdigen Winkel
geparkt so als habe es da jemand sehr
eilig gehabt und am Türgriff der
Fahrerseite sind Blutspuren okay also da
ist Blut vielleicht ist jemand verletzt
vielleicht ist OJ Simpson in Gefahr
demselben Mörder zum Opfer zu fallen
oder was auch immer die Polizisten
wissen auf jeden Fall dass sie handeln
müssen
klar absurder Gedanke im Nachhinein dass
ich die Polizisten Sorgen um OJ Simpson
machen aber in der Nacht und dort vor
Ort sah die Sache ganz sicher anders aus
auf jeden Fall ist keine Zeit zu
verlieren einer der Detectives klettert
über den Zaun sein Name ist Mark Forman
und genau diesen mag Firmen sind wir
schon in Folge 1 begegnet denn der wurde
einmal wegen häuslicher Gewalt zum Haus
der Simpsons gerufen als die noch
verheiratet waren genau und Mark Formen
wird im Folgenden noch eine ziemlich
wichtige Rolle spielen jetzt aber
klettert er erstmal über den Zaun und
lässt seine Kollegen rein kurz darauf
treffen die Beamten auf Kate okin einen
Kumpel von Simpson der zur Zeit in einem
Gästehaus auf dem Grundstück wohnt er
aber abends noch einen Burger mit
Simpson gegessen aber in der Nacht sah
er dann von einer Limousine abgeholt
worden die ihn zum Flughafen bringen
sollte
es sind die frühen Morgenstunden des 13
Juni 1994 und Audi Simpson ist zu dieser
Zeit längst in Chicago gelandet einer
der Detektiv ruft ihn dort in seinem
Hotel an und erzählt ihm vom Tod seiner
Exfrau
Simpsons Reaktionen überrascht ihm
ziemlich er scheint nämlich nur eine
einzige Frage zu haben
haben die Kinder den Mord oder die
Leiche gesehen
wo man doch eigentlich vermuten sollte
dass sie jeder Vater sofort fragen würde
ist den Kindern etwas passiert sind sie
in Sicherheit
es sei denn natürlich er wüsste sehr gut
dass der Mörder den Kindern nichts
angetan hat und ihn niemals etwas antun
wird
so gut wie es nur der Mörder selber
wissen kann
kurz darauf entdeckt Detective Firmen
den Zwillingsbruder des
zweitberühmtesten Handschuhs der Welt
und zwar ja auf o.j Simpsons Grundstück
okay also du meinst einfach den
berühmtesten Handschuh der Welt ja du
hast recht der berühmteste Handschuh der
Welt ein extra großer leichter rechter
Lederhandschuh das Gegenstück zu dem der
auch am Tatort gefunden wurde und diesen
Handschuh den sie da auf oJ Simpsons
Grundstück finden der ist voller Blut
damit konzentrieren sich die
Ermittlungen fast nur noch auf einen
Verdächtigen
noch am selben Tag kommt Simpson
freiwillig aus Chicago zurück und wird
vernommen und diese Vernehmung ist
ziemlich seltsam das ist definitiv kein
Verhör dass es eher eine Plauderei
Simpson kann nicht genau angeben wann er
um den Tatzeitpunkt herum wo war die
Polizisten akzeptieren das einfach er
hat kein richtiges Alibi abends hat er
einen Burger mit Kälte Kellen gegessen
danach war er eine unbestimmte Zeit lang
alleine bis die Limousine ihn abholte
die Polizisten Haken auch nicht nach
aber sie sprechen ihn auf seine
gewalttätigen Übergriffe gegen Nicole
während der Ehe an
er spielt die herunter und tut sie als
Schnee von gestern ab und die Polizisten
die nehmen das hin und so weiter und so
weiter ihr könnt es euch vorstellen
besonders bizarres Detail den ermitteln
fällt ein Schnitt an einem der Finger
der linken Hand auf sie wissen dass der
Mörder an der linken Hand verletzt ist
ja und ratet mal was sie machen
sie geben ihm ein Pflaster okay wir
wollen jetzt nicht ungerecht sein
natürlich befragen Sie ihn auch zu
dieser Wunde er sagt er habe sie sich im
Hotel in Chicago zugezogen als sie ihn
daraufhin mit dem Blut auf dem Türgriff
seines Wagens konfrontieren ändert er
seine Story ach ja er habe sich am Tag
zuvor verletzt wisse aber nicht mehr
genau wo und wer ja und dann lassen Sie
ihn einfach gehen es ist fast als
wollten sie gar nicht
dass er der Mörder ist und vielleicht
stimmt das irgendwo sogar der Mann ist
ein Star und wird von der ganzen Nation
bewundert und geliebt vielleicht finden
sie es insgeheim auch cool mit so
jemanden berühmten zu quatschen und
wollen ihn dann natürlich nicht
verärgern sondern ihm gefallen
vielleicht ist aber auch ein bisschen
Angst dabei wer reich und berühmt ist
hat sicher auch jede Menge Möglichkeiten
einem kleinen Mord Ermittler das Leben
zur Hölle zu machen
die nächsten Tage die Tage bevor er
schließlich unter bizarren Umständen
verhaftet wird würden Stoff für einen
eigenen Dreiteiler hergeben es ist ein
einziger Kampf zwischen der zögerlichen
Polizei den Anwälten von Simpson und
Staatsanwältin Marsha Clark die Simpsons
von Tag eins an hinter Gittern sehen
wollte und die jedes Vertrauen in die
Ermittler verloren hat seit sie die
Abschrift der ersten Vernehmung gelesen
hat
verständlich
inzwischen kommt auch ein wahnsinniger
Druck von außen auf alle Beteiligten
dazu die Medien sind sofort auf diese
Geschichte aufgesprungen der Mordfall
ist das Thema im Juni 1994 und bei allem
was die Beteiligten tun müssen sie sich
ganz genau überlegen wie sie es in der
Öffentlichkeit darstellen lässt
am 17 Juni empfehlen die Ermittler
Simpson wegen zweifachen Mordes ersten
Grades anzuklagen inzwischen haben die
DNA-Analysen ergeben dass die
Blutstropfen auf Nicole Browns
Grundstück das Blut an dem Handschuh auf
Simpsons Grundstück und weitere Spuren
mit einer an Sicherheit grenzenden
Wahrscheinlichkeit von o.j Simpson
stammen aber trotz der offensichtlich
erdrückenden Beweislast wird og Simpson
nicht verhaftet man schon die noch immer
und verhandelt mit seinen Anwälten die
unter allen Umständen verhindern wollen
dass Bilder ihres Mandanten um die Welt
gehen wir mit Handschellen abgeführt
wird und inzwischen warten mehr als 1000
Reporter und tausende Schaulustige in
Los Angeles auf genau dieses Bild aus
Rücksicht und weil man nicht von einer
Fluchtgefahr ausgeht teilt das Los
Angeles Police Department dem Anwalt
Robert Shapiro mit dass ich Simpson bis
11 Uhr stellen müssen
hält sich zu Zeit im Haus eines weiteren
seine Anwälte auf und dessen Name dürfte
einigen bekannt vorkommen Robert
Kardashian ja der Vater von Kim
Kardashian
Simpson bekommt noch einen weiteren
Aufschub doch er verpasst den Termin
daraufhin teilt die Polizei Shapiro mit
dass man den Verdächtigen demnächst im
Haus von Robert Kardashian verhaften
würde als die Polizei eine Stunde nach
Ankündigung bei seinem Anwalt anrückt
ist Simpson zusammen mit einem Freund
namens el Colin verschwunden
Simpson wird zum flüchtigen erklärt und
zur Fahndung ausgeschrieben und damit
kommen wir zu einer der berühmtesten
Verfolgungsjagden aller Zeiten also ich
würde sie jetzt nicht die spannendste
nennen weil es nicht wie in so
Actionfilm ist irgendwie mit
quietschenden Reifen man sieht ja
eigentlich nur wie ein Auto die ganze
Zeit den Highway lang brettert dass das
Ganze aber natürlich so berühmt und
spektakulär macht ist ich versuche das
jetzt mal ins Deutsche zu holen das ist
als ob Günther ja auch vor der Polizei
fliehen würde und Kameras halten die
ganze Zeit drauf ja klar du hast
natürlich recht redet man von einer der
spannendsten und aufregendsten
Verfolgungsjagden dann würde man
wahrscheinlich eine Menge Explosion und
diesen ganzen Blabla und dieses ganz
Blabla erwarten aber nicht jeder Krimi
ist auch gleichzeitig ein Hollywood
action thriller
bei dieser Verfolgungsjagd da ging es
vielleicht gar nicht so sehr darum was
geschehen ist sondern vielleicht viel
mehr um das was vielleicht noch
geschehen würde aber erzählen wir
erstmal die Fakten okay gegen 18 Uhr 20
meldet ein Autofahrer in Orange County
der California Highway Patrol er habe
o.j Simpson in einem weißen Ford Bronko
auf dem Freeway Interstate 5 in Richtung
Norden gesehen eine Polizeibeamtin ist
als erste bei dem Fahrzeug des
Flüchtenden als sie den Bronco einholt
schreibt ihr el kaulings der am Steuer
sitzt zu dass OJ Simpson auf dem
Rücksitze und eine Waffe auf seinen
eigenen Kopf gerichtet habe das klingt
glaubwürdig denn vorher ist ein Brief
von Simpson gefunden worden der als
Abschiedsbrief interpretiert werden kann
die Polizistin lässt sich zurückfallen
Verstärkung trifft ein schließlich
Folgen 20 Polizeiwagen den weißen Ford
Bronco ja aber es ist alles nicht mit
sondern 35 Meilen pro Stunde das sind 56
km/h also wirklich eine recht
gemächliche Angelegenheit zu den
Polizeifahrzeugen gesellen sich bei zehn
Hubschrauber von Fernsehgesellschaften
die die Verfolgungsjagd in die
amerikanischen Wohnzimmer übertragen und
die ganze Nation ist gebannt dabei ein
zur selben Zeit laufendes wichtige Spiel
des Super Bowl wird unterbrochen oder
die Sender Teilen im Bildschirm z.B um
Spiel und ja gleichzeitig zeigen zu
können und dabei auch noch zu
kommentieren
tausende strömt zur Interstate um live
dabei zu sein dank der Live-Bilder aus
den Hubschraubern kann man ja auch sehr
gut voraussagen wann er wo auftauchen
wird viele von ihnen rufen go oje go und
genau das ist der Slogan aus den
Fernsehspots die o.j für die
Autovermietung Herz gedreht hat aber wo
will er hin was hat er vor Simpson
verspricht der Polizei am Telefon erneut
sich zu stellen vorher aber wolle er mit
seiner Mutter sprechen die
Verfolgungsjagd endet gegen 20 Uhr in
brandwood wo seine Mutter lebt Samsung
bleibt gut eine Dreiviertelstunde im
Bronco sitzen beobachtet von swa-teams
regulären Polizisten und den
nachrichtenteams in den Hubschraubern
dann geht er ins Haus und bleibt dort
etwa eine Stunde ein Polizeisprecher
erklärt später er habe dort mit seiner
Mutter gesprochen und ein Glas
Orangensaft getrunken
schließlich trifft Shapiro ein einer
seiner Anwälte
ein paar Minuten später stellt sich og
Simpson und wird verhaftet
also man kann schon von der
Sonderbehandlung sprechen
wir haben in den Jahren so viel darüber
gehört wie brutal die Polizei oft gegen
schwarze Verdächtige vorgeht und die
Polizei von Los Angeles hat da einen
besonders schlechten Ruf
1992 hatten hier Polizisten brutal auf
Rodney King eingeprügelt und waren
später frei gesprochen worden was
natürlich zu tagelang
bürgerkriegsähnlichen Zuständen mit 53
Toten führte kein gutes Pflaster also
eigentlich für schwarze die egal ob
schuldig oder unschuldig mit der Polizei
in Kontakt kommen aber ohje ist
prominent und das hatten wir ja schon in
Folge 1 wahnsinnig beliebt sogar unter
Leuten die man einfach als Rassisten
bezeichnen muss
und man will auch ehrlich gesagt nicht
mit den Beamten tauschen die da die
Entscheidungen treffen die einen
eventuell bevorstehenden Selbstmord oder
eine gewaltsame Auseinandersetzung
verhindern mussten und das alles unter
den Augen von schätzungsweise 95
Millionen live fernsehzuschauerern der
Verdächtige ist also verhaftet die
Beweise scheinen eindeutig und damit ist
alles bereit für den dritten Akt dieses
Dramas den Mordprozess gegen OJ Simpson
und genau darum wird sich alles im
dritten und letzten Teil unserer
Miniserie hier bei Tatort Deutschland
drehen und wir freuen uns natürlich wenn
auch da wieder mit dabei seid vielen
Dank fürs Zuhören euren Wirkung und eure
Toni